in honor of
the fact that and in an effort to get
the word out to anyone who may have any
uncertainty about this don't put your
gasoline in plastic bags today's draft
the dumbest moves
of the nfl offseason assuming that there
are no teams out there that put their
gasoline in plastic bags that would be
number one
we move on now to other things that were
done that maybe shouldn't have been done
miles i'll give you the honors first
pick goes to you dumbest off season
moves
2021 you're up okay uh i i don't want to
feel like i'm a hater on this team but
like i feel like there were maybe three
or four things that they've done over
the course of this offseason that i
could use for this segment but i'll say
this the raiders signed kenyon drake
running back to a deal for two years 11
million
with eight and a half million guaranteed
why would you do that in the year of our
lord 2021 for your running back
i don't i just i don't understand and
like i know that they tried this thing
with lynn bowden last year or they
wanted to convert him into like a flex
guy where he can play running back and
then wide receiver and they think kenyon
drake can do that but i think still just
are they gonna trade him now like a
third round pick before he even plays a
snap so that's really the lin bone roll
i just
i think that there are other ways of
getting that role done than signing your
running back when you already have josh
jacobs who's gonna be your number one
guy
for eight and a half million guaranteed
and that's right they have josh jacobs
on a rookie contract who's making a lot
less than that and he's their workhorse
so it makes no sense you could find
somebody for a lot cheaper you could get
lucky and get somebody in round five or
six of the draft who can maybe do what
kenyon drake would do and dollar for
dollar it's going to be a better value
i have to go with a topic that we
discussed earlier in the program the
panthers trading a sixth round pick a
fourth round pick and a second round
pick next year a second round pick when
you're gonna actually be able to scout
in a way that you weren't able to scout
this year that second round pick is
gonna have a lot of value plenty of
great players coming round two for sam
darnold why because they're so desperate
to find a franchise quarterback and they
didn't want to roll the dice on none of
the great quarterbacks in 2021 being
left when they picked at number eight
overall and as it turned out
they would have had mac jones they would
have had justin fields and i thought
that this was like next level david
tepper hedge fund stuff where
he instead of paying the price to move
up which would have been a lot more
expensive
you pay the price to get sam darnold as
your insurance
and also as
you know the fact that he's on the
roster it keeps someone from jumping
over you and then you can get justin
fields or mac jones i really thought
they were going to take one of those
quarterbacks at number eight so i just
for a team that is desperate for a
franchise quarterback
i i think that this investment and hey i
could be wrong darnold may end up being
the guy that colin coward thought he was
going to be i don't know if you saw that
video making the rounds low end andrew
luck high-end brett favre maybe that's
what sam darnold will become with the
panthers but to me i just think that
it's way too much to give up simply
because they didn't want to let the
board play out and get one of the
rookies he had the worst passer rating
of any quarterback in 2020 worse than
that of carson wentz all right and i
think everybody you know
knows that carson wins did not pass any
sort of eye test last year look sam
darnold is a history of turnovers
whether it was at usc or with the jets
i think that you could be right that uh
the panthers could certainly be in the
same position that they are currently in
you know when they wanted to get sam
darnold for instead of teddy bridgewater
they could be in the same position a
year from now and having to draft
somebody or sign somebody else in free
agency so i i certainly agree with you
there uh here's my next one i think the
ravens trading a left tackle to the top
dog in the conference it's something
that i'm gonna shake my head over and
it's something that i literally just
praised brett beach for and i understand
that and i think that they did a great
job but look you even asked spread about
this man like when you're getting a guy
who is on a team that's one of your
rivals in the conference
for the top spot there and you're
competing with to get into the super
bowl it's either well you know what we
really don't believe in this guy or
maybe you're doing something that you
shouldn't quite do to help the team
that's been in the super bowl for the
last two years so i know it's like it
reminds me of when the cavs traded kyrie
irving to the boston celtics you don't
trade that guy to the top competitor in
the conference you trade him to be
wherever your sport siberia is that's
where you let him go be a left tackle
and they didn't do that they sent him to
the chiefs they got a first round pick
for him but we'll see if it actually
works out and the fallout fails you put
him in john coon's trunk uh the next one
for me is
that's a joke if you if you weren't
watching the show earlier
you really
you really aren't going to get that one
it's that one's all in good
orlando brown wouldn't he wouldn't fit
in john coon's trunk i'm fairly
confident saying that you're gonna
that's one of those where you have to
get a bungee cord you know when you've
got something really big in the trunk
and you gotta hold it together
[Laughter]
um
okay
he will i will find you
i will find you
uh okay
um
i gotta go with the jaguars
considering tim tebow even if they don't
sign him and i suspect that they will
the other day urban meyer tells chris
collinsworth hey i told the guys let's
give it a shot but we haven't signed him
yet let's give it a shot i think there's
there's two reasons they haven't signed
them yet and one of them is they got to
figure out what they're doing with
gardner minshew so they know that number
15 will be available to sell all of
those tim tebow jerseys that people are
going to buy right out of the gates and
here's the one time tim tebow played
tight end in his career urban meyer said
he's got great ball skills i'd hate to
see what that play would have looked
like if he didn't have great ball skills
and i have a feeling they're going to
run it again so we can fully appreciate
moving right to left in the shotgun
formation and there's the throw and it
boom right off the helmet great ball
skills that would count as a completion
in electric football so maybe he's
working at a level that the rest of us
aren't i uh
look they leak it
the same day that trevor lawrence is
going to become the new face of the
franchise they leaked that they worked
him out what what's the what's what is
that what do you what are you doing
embrace trevor lawrence you don't need
to dust off tim tebow a guy that hasn't
played in the nfl in nine years it's a
gimmick
it's an effort to sell jerseys it's an
effort to sell tickets and a miles i'm a
firm believer if he's on the 90-man
roster you're going to see him in a
uniform now it may be i mean in
september it may be practice squad and
he gets elevated because there's two
guys a week you can move up to the
active roster we're going to see him in
uniform and here's the other side of it
too and i thought of this during the
break haha clinton dick's first round
pick in 2014 was out of football last
year because he had a guaranteed salary
from the bears and he just didn't play
for anyone
he's participating in the texans rookie
mini camp this weekend on a tryout basis
why not have tim tebow participate in
the jaguars rookie mini camp on a tryout
basis let's see what he can do against
the rookies before you sign him it's
just it tells me it's preordained it's
predetermined it's a gimmick anyway go
ahead you're up
well i i didn't like that either and
that was on my list and there's the
other thing that i could have said right
here which is that nfl allowing single
digit numbers for like you know
defensive backs
i won't say that i won't i'm gonna go
with cincinnati passing on penny sewell
and drafting jamar chase and i think
that you know what jamar chase could be
an excellent receiver he and joe burrow
could continue that excellent chemistry
that they had at lsu but when you've
basically been spinning your wheels and
trying to replace andrew whitworth since
2016 when he left and then went to the
los angeles rams for the 2017 season
you don't have that guy that's
entrenched as a left tackle somebody
like penne sewell you pair him with joe
burrow you have your quarterback in your
left tackle maybe for 10 years and i
mean look jamar chase and joe burrow
could be the next montana to rice or
young to rice whichever one you want to
use but i
i just feel like when you have a chance
to get a left tackle that's something
that you really probably should do
especially when your quarterback is
coming off a devastating knee injury
the last one for me and there's a bunch
of different ways i could go here
the lions trading for jared goff i don't
really think that was a good idea even
though they picked up probably a
first-round pick to do it the rams using
the first round tender on darius
williams we've talked about that before
even the steelers bringing back ben
roethlisberger i think both sides are
going to regret that come december but i
i'll just say everything the texans have
done
in the off-season it was overshadowed
once desean watson's legal issues arose
but everything they've done and it all
traces back to jackie used to be frankly
comedic stylings of jackie's to be just
go to youtube and you can entertain
yourself for about 45 minutes with uh
all sorts of different uh
jokes or attempt they're at but
everything they've done miles everything
they've done
with the exception maybe of signing
tyrod taylor everything they've done is
a dumb move
oh it's all been very very head
scratching and i would guess that davis
mills also falls under the consideration
of not too dumb either but mostly other
than that yes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports